بعد ساعه من الان تبدا مواجهه ساخنه بين
المنتخبين السعودي والمكسيكي بالتوازي مع
مواجهه لا تقل سخونه بين الارجنتين
وبولاندا حظوظ المنتخبات الاربعه متساويه
في تاهل للدوري القادم وان كانت المكسيك
اقل حظا من البقيه ثلاثه نقاط اخرى يقاتل
الاخضر اليوم للحصول عليها ليضمن بها
التاهل وخلف الاخضر ملايين العيون المسمر
على شاشات في المنازل والمقاهي وداخل
الملعب تتمنى تاهل اولى المنتخبات العربيه
للدور ال 16 في الدوحه البيت السعودي جاهز
لمباراه العمره وكالعاده العربيه اول
الحاضرين مع الزميل ليس بازاري فن
المتابعه
نحن هنا في البيت السعودي الذي يعد ملتقى
مشجعين المنتخب السعودي من كافه الجنسيات
يعد هذا المكان الذي يمتد على مساحه 18
الف متر مكان لقاء المشجعين فالكثير منهم
يقصده قبل الانطلاق الى الملاعب التي
يواجه فيها المنتخب خصومه الهدف من هذا
المكان هو اثراء تجربه المشجعين السعوديين
في مونديال قطر 2022 والتعريف الثقافه
السعوديه اذا يستمتع الزوار بتجربه لاعب
كره القدم مع كبار اللاعبين افتراديا في
جناح الاحلام عبر تقنيه الواقع المعزز
والواقع الافتراضي اضافه الى تجربه
التصوير مع تشكيله المنتخب السعودي
افتراضيه
ويستطيع الشهور بكره القدم متابعه مباريات
المونديال عبر شاشه عرض ضخمه الى جانب
مساحه خضراء تتسع لاعاده كبير من مشجعين
المنتخب السعودي الذي سيواجه المنتخب
المكسيكي اليوم ليلا في ملعب لوسيل هنا في
الدوحه كما تحتل الاكلات السعوديه قوائم
الماكولات التي تمكن ضيوف البيت السعودي
من تناولها كما يتسوق المشجعون من متجر
الصقور الخضر الذي على زي المنتخب
الرسمي بالاضافه الى اعلام وشعارات
المنتخب السعودي
العربيه الدوحه دوله قطر